apple ha detto a tutti e come dire ho
scelto di parlare di questo argomento in
maniera abbastanza intima personale e
come se nella mia testa mi fossi fatto
un piccolo film partendo anche dalla mia
dalla mia infanzia e in compagnia della
mia vita così vorrei parlare di questo
di questi questo senso di questo
sentimento di questo oggetto che
l'intuizione e vorrei partire un po da
lontano se avete un attimo di pazienza e
partire proprio dai sensi voglio dire
quando si nasce in realtà i sensi sono 5
quelli che sentiamo quelli che anche il
mondo esterno ci porta a come dire a
crescere educare ma io sono ovviamente
tutti noi sappiamo che sensi sono almeno
due in più e mi riferisco soprattutto
quello della dell'immaginazione cioè il
bambino vive con l'immaginazione
l'immaginazione è come dire la
possibilità di giocare la possibilità di
difendersi dal mondo degli adulti la
possibilità come dire a volte di
immaginare anche una strada una salvezza
se penso al film di bergman a fanny
alexander
il ragazzino si salva immagina di fa
bruciare il patrigno il padrino o brucia
dico questo perché io sono stato sempre
nessuna con un'immaginazione molto molto
forte molto una bambina che comunque mi
sembra di vedere il diavolo oppure che
mio fratello diceva c'è una madonna in
bagno
trovo in bagno per due anni e quindi
come dire ho vissuto con questo
sentimento ma ho vissuto con con con
solitudine tanto che mi ricordo che una
volta che ho visto una gallina chiudere
l'occhio al contrario sono state dorizza
ta ho detto non ho detto a nessuno
perché ho detto oh un'allucinazione
l'immaginazione si sta prendendo la mia
realtà ed ero ammutolita
in realtà scusatemi
in realtà dopo due giorni ho capito che
la gallina chiude l'occhio al contrario
e quindi mi sono come dire rassicurata
questo per dire che i sensi a mio avviso
non sono cinque ma nessuno sei o sette
anzi 7 l'immaginazione che il bambino
nasce con si sviluppa e cresce si
difende ma il mondo degli adulti il
mondo esterno
in qualche modo lo obbliga a mettere
questo giocattolo dentro un soffitto e
una soffitta e l'istinto l'istinto che
rimane soltanto quello di cadere non
farsi male io personalmente penso che
quando cade si fa sempre male
questo anche per dire che questi sensi
sono personali c'è qualcuno che ne ha
uno più sviluppato uno meno sviluppato
quindi partendo dal fatto che i sensi
sono sette e non 5 e che questi due sono
fondamentali sono fondamentali anche non
cioè dargli una quotidianità farli
crescere insieme a noi
e l'intuizione dove arriva l'infezione
in realtà è proprio così
secondo una mia è proprio l'unione di
questi due sensi cioè da una parte
dell'immaginario e dall'altra parte
dell'istinto l'intuizione quasi
un'elaborazione quasi una voglia
grandi di conservare questi due
giocattoli di non metterli lontani e di
creare voglio dire un ponte
importantissimo tra quello che il nostro
interno e quello che il nostro esterno
cioè è un'elaborazione e comunque la
voglia di prendere dal dall'esterno
rielaborare in maniera assolutamente
istintiva e avere una non una soluzione
ma un'intuizione mi mi spiego meglio
nel corso del tempo io poi un po
casualmente un po perché forse ho
seguito il mio il mio istinto mi sono
trovata a lavorare con la creatività e
la creatività è proprio e proprio come
dire è uno strumento intuitivo e uno
strumento che non nasce con delle regole
razionali o empiriche ma è proprio
quella quel desiderio quella volontà da
che dall'interno va best verso l'esterno
insomma l'intuizione viene percepita
come un lampo di genio come qualcosa che
ti arriva addosso ma nessuno neanche i
più grandi neanche a ti media
in realtà lavoravano sull'intuizione era
era un modo di ascoltare e di mettere in
contatto l'interno con l'esterno
diciamo che nel campo artistico io
identifico ma non solo io
l'intuizione con la poetica immaginavo
una clessidra e ritorniamo quindi
all'inizio l'essere umano prende
dall'esterno prende dall'esterno in una
maniera intuitiva
l'intuizione è la capacità di prendere
dei dettagli dell'area cioè quando si
dice ha avuto l'intuizione un'intuizione
che nasce dal comportamento che nasce da
come i tuoi sensi percepiscono l'esterno
viene viene trattata dentro dentro ti fa
o come dire elabori il tuo mondo
personale unico
e a quel punto lì l'idea di gridarlo con
degli strumenti realistici con un
oggettivazione che è l'arte non so come
dire lo si dà tramite l'immaginazione
quindi quei due elementi iniziali che
sono l'istinto e l'immaginazione è in
realtà nella sintesi diventano come dire
un un percorso immaginario di andare
avanti e indietro tra un mondo oggettivo
in un mondo soggettivo il che è la
chiusura del cerchio è una cosa molto
molto piacevole
io però ho pensato anche a un'intuizione
quando parlo di un'intuizione un lato a
un lato b un'intuizione primaria è
un'intuizione secondaria perdonatemi io
devo bere molto cioè se l'intuizione
primaria corrisponde come dire al al
mondo poetico non voler scomodare c'è
pieno piuttosto che pasolini perché poi
questo mondo poetico deve trovare forme
deve trovare forme in una comunicazione
perché è quello là la bellezza e che
l'immaginario e per l'essere umano come
una macchina del tempo che ci permette
di andare avanti indietro e creare un
altro tempo quindi se c'è da una parte
il mondo poetico un immaginario primario
io ho immaginato anche un immaginare un
lato be diciamo di questo immaginario ho
detto all'inizio mi sono stata molto
molto fortunata
il c io ho il cinema diciamo non è che
l'ho cercato mi è venuta un po addosso
come un po mi è venuto addosso tutta
tutta la vita cioè nel senso che mi
capita una cosa la faccio come dire mi
capita di parlare dell'intuizione sento
che la cosa mi mi può arricchire mipo mi
può dare
curiosità che mi può far creare questo
meccanismo 3 interno esterno di così
sono qua e mi ci metto a pensare così
col cinema io non è che ho deciso come
appunto si fa dopo faccio il cinema il
cinema e mi è finito addosso ma è
veramente quel tipo di d arte che più ma
io credo che sia stato un incontro molto
fortunato e e se questo incontro c'è
stato c'è stato grazie alla comunque
all'intuizione di sentire che quella era
una strada giusta perché quando prima si
parlava appunto di delle scelte come
l'intuizione è anche e soprattutto
scelta una scelta che non deve essere
una scelta razionale empirica ma una
scelta che non fatta dire se stessi che
questi mette in ascom che ti mette in
ascolto
ecco allora il cinema ha questa
caratteristica che l'unica forma di arte
l'unica che che collettiva che non dove
l'artista non è solo perché se noi
pensiamo a al mondo poetico e ad un
artista pensiamo come una persona che ha
un mondo interno una profondità un a
volte bella brutta chi ha il bisogno e
la voglia di trovare una forma una
comunicazione esattamente il processo
inverso che cioè dall interno va verso
verso l'esterno
ed è un processo che non può passare
attraverso le regole della
della ragione assolutamente cioè nel
senso che il processo creativo è una
cosa anzi che ti mette in allenamento
l'intuizione perché tu sai se io penso
il mio primo film il mio primo film era
la voglia di una ragazzina
io di ribellarmi alla vita come dire
alla vita segnata a quello che dovevo
diventare grandi a quelle tappe
conosciute e io ero lì che studi che
avevo capito qual'era cioè la mia la mia
intuizione ma gli dovevo dare forma e la
forma in realtà l'hanno trovato degli
anziani di 60 anni cioè in realtà in
qualcosa che è diverso e molto diverso
da me ritornando al cinema il cinema
invece un arte collettiva che ti
permette non solo di parlare di
un'intuizione primaria ma ti permette di
lavorare con un'equipe di persone con
una collettività rispetto a una visione
interna rispetto a una sensibilità
rispetto a uno spirito cioè di voler
dare corpo tramite un immagine che è
fatta di scenografia costumi e quindi
sono tante persone e tante tante
creatività che si uniscono insieme e
anche nel nella scelta di un vestito
nella scelta che da presentazione cioè
che e ci vuole un intuizione giornaliera
quotidiana
un'intuizione che fatta in un film
storico dove io partivo dal fatto che
ripercorreva la storia della
protagonista attraverso l'idea che negli
ultimi minuti della vita uno rivive la
propria esistenza
allora a questo punto quindi era uno
andare avanti dietro era molto costoso e
la costumista mi ha detto atleta
vogliamo fare solo due costumi
io ho detto no facciamo un unico costume
perché ho sentito subito che c'era
qualcosa di molto interessante quello
che diceva l'intuizione di averla
ascoltata e un'intuizione che nasce da
una collaborazione fa sì che anche
l'estetica di quel film ne ha guadagnato
perché non c'era non andare avanti
indietro
cambiare si poteva ed è proprio lì che
le intuizioni cioè voglio dire
funzionano quando sia il mondo interno
che il mondo esterno sia le regole
empiriche sia quelle profonde che non
non sono conosciute trovano un tutt'uno
quello che devo al cinema è proprio la
capacità di capire che come dire
l'intuizione l'immaginazione l'istinto
sono dei sentimenti sono dei sensi delle
capacità che non vanno messe nel nel
soffitto fanno vanno usate vanno usate
anche giornalmente anche per per la vita
per la vita quotidiana e io questo credo
che lo devo in una maniera
e proprio nel cinema cioè io ero una
bambina piena di immaginazione piena di
sensibilità e avevo paura di tutto ciò
il cinema e l'arte invece ha trovato la
capacità di non reprimere tutto questo
ma di alimentare un intuizione
un'intuizione quotidiana che io vivo
anche giorno giorno per giorno e che
secondo me tutti i bambini dovrebbero
tenerselo non troppo grande non troppo
piccolo ha tanto agli altri cinque sensi
in realtà ce ne sono sette e secondo me
con l'intuizione sono otto